[Applause]
[Music]
man can you guys believe valve just
dropped half like three on us like that
oh wait we're past April Fool's Day crap
well there's still plenty of games on
the way so be sure to subscribe to be
the first to know the lineup each and
every week let's see what's on the menu
when it comes to stylish RPGs it doesn't
get much bigger than persona and persona
5 is a new adventure nine years in the
making here to tell us more is new
releases UK correspondent Lucy James
thanks Tony yep asana five is finally
out this week after almost a decade
since persona 4 and it's totally been
worth the wait I mean you have a talking
cat called Morgana who lives in your bag
and you can have multiple wife who's my
wife he was called on and she's the best
yours like a student and you have to do
exams and stuff which is kind of sucks
but at the same time you're a thief and
you go into people's mind palaces and
you steal their hearts and it's just so
good and you should check out my review
on gamespot com huh persona 5 hits ps4
and ps3 on Tuesday April fourth and if
you want to hear Lucy gush about it some
more check out the full review over on
gamespot lego city undercover was once a
wii u exclusive but now it's coming to
all the current platforms it's basically
Grand Theft Auto with legos where police
officer chase McCain hunts down
criminals across an open world and since
it's a lego game chase can build plenty
of handy tools we're sneaky disguises
and hop into the driver's seat of plenty
of fun vehicles lego city undercover is
headed a ps4 xbox one pc and nintendo
switch on April fourth what's the next
game from the creator of God of War if
you guess drawn to death a third person
shooter that looks like a high schooler
sketchbook you'd be correct and your
prize is an arena shooter with a cast of
Totally Rad characters with their own
special buffs and attacks plus a whole
bunch of crazy power-ups like a flame
throwing lizard creator david jaffe also
drove the twisted metal series back in
the day and drawn to death Serena's
feature the same attention to detail and
hidden secrets if that sounds good to
you and you're a PlayStation Plus member
I
even better news it's free for you with
the PS Plus April games lineup which
goes live on April fourth let's take a
break from shooting each other with
black wood crossing orphan brother and
sister Finn and scarlet are the stars of
this adventure game which drops them on
to a haunted train full of ghosts now
I'm no literature professor but there's
a serious metaphor going on there and
the more you uncover on this train the
more you'll learn about the divide
between these siblings you can start
your emotional journey on ps4 xbox one
and pc on the fourth ok back to shooting
people Bulletstorm is known for a few
things damn it [ __ ] glorious
mother [ __ ] mostly just the swearing but
also a bunch of crazy guns and ugly
monsters the remaster will let you slay
them all over again with better textures
4k support the gun sonata and blood
Symphony expansions and for those who
pre-ordered an all new campaign starring
Duke Nukem you can start pulling off all
those back-breaking not cracking skill
shots on ps4 xbox one and pc on april
seven and those are the big games will
be playing this week as always remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys and I'll be
back with more next week
[Music]